[Music]
hello blackberry
the other visionaries and i officially
request killing cults becomes your top
priority
or in other words murder the bastard now
every single person here's out to kill
me it's fun
i've been cutting short your meaningless
rampages for some time
it's totally normal death is a typical
physiological experience in this place i
hate to break it to you but there is
nothing normal
about this [ __ ] island oh
[ __ ]
you're gonna give me that attitude
same day which means i already know
what's going to happen
am i supposed to do this every day for
the rest of my life
[ __ ] that i'm breaking this loop i'm
dinger game director at arcane leon and
i'm here to give you a special look
at desloop you are cold
you're stuck in a time loop on the
island of black reef where everybody
wants you dead
to escape you'll have to take out eight
targets known as the visionaries before
the day repeats
also one of your targets juliana is in
the business of hunting you down
fail to kill the target or die
and the day starts over oh you gotta be
kidding me
but every loop is an opportunity with
every cycle you will learn more about
the visionaries and the secrets of the
island by exploring and observing
you will discover their habits and
secrets using that knowledge to progress
through the story
let's jump into a mission several hours
into the game to see cold
take on the visionary alexis the wolf
dorsey
at this point you have already learned
from a previous loop that alexis plans
to give a speech
at his well-guarded masquerade party
let's use that intel
to identify alexis and take him down
i was just thinking i want to know what
the [ __ ] is going on oh you don't want
that
you're looking for purpose i'm looking
for the fastest way out of this place
there are rules called and sometimes
people bend the rules and sometimes they
break them blah blah blah
are you talking when i was talking i
have top secret information
okay what is it i said it was top secret
i've thought about it and uh i think i'm
doing
everyone here a favor by ending this so
what happens when you break the loop
seriously i want your theories
everything goes back to normal obviously
normal you have absolutely no [ __ ]
idea what will happen
true but i know one way to find out
dying isn't the end reprise is one of
the powers you can unlock it allows you
to die and rewind
twice before the blueprint starts you
have also seen carnesis that allows you
to yank enemies around
and shift the short range teleport hey
we killed you
do you need my help no i'm fine getting
yourself killed
he's
here's where court died you can absorb
your body to regain residium a resource
that allows you to save your favorite
weapons and abilities between loops
over time you will build an arsenal of
weapons abilities and upgrades that you
can mix and match between missions to
suit your playstyle or the needs of a
specific task
we use the haptic feedback and the
adaptive trigger of the ps5 dual sense
controller to bring an extra layer of
immersion to your experience
every movement feels different and
weapons express their personality in the
palm of your hands
[Music]
very impressive i'm clapping with one
hand
don't stop there put them both together
the body count is gonna get high i
need an invitation to alexis's party i
found another way in
through the window no no i'm not
climbing on any cliff or window just
shut up keep your eyes open there's
always multiple ways to approach a
target
and we just learned of one the back
entrance to the mansion
conversations like this happen all over
black reef and it often pays to stop and
listen
[Music]
like what
that alert means your rival juliana has
invaded your game
controlled by another player or the ai
she's the real deal
you'll have to be extra vigilant when
she's on the hunt
wow i didn't know you like to party
ain't my style
uh you're all business all the time
aren't you what is your style exactly
[Music]
when i should be killing [ __ ]
apparently
[Music]
[ __ ] the wolves play a sick game
whoever fails to impress the others with
their evil deeds
goes into the grinder and onto the
dinner menu
let's see if we can rig the outcome
[Music]
but it could also be another mass
speaker so let's hear him out
and not take the shot there were deaths
lawsuits whatever
profits far outstretched our small legal
fees we made
millions that year chief masters who
died
they could have afforded it arrogant
cruel no regard for others yeah
that's definitely alexis
and yup alexis just dropped an upgrade
to the carnacy's power
and a hefty dose of residue time to get
the hell out of here what are you doing
up there
[Music]
hey
[Music]
me
[Music]
fight
[Music]
why wasn't i invited
you're gonna call me like this all the
time julie juliana
i give approximately zero [ __ ] about
what you call yourself
but you did once
hmm
playstation
you